- Hello!
We are acc—why am I yelling?
I'm not gonna yell this time.
I didn't wanna yell.
That's why I went really calm
the last time.
- OK, but you're a yeller.
You have a big f--kin' mouth.
Be Adam Lefkoe.
What are you gonna, f--kin' be
somebody else now?
Let's go.
- We took our act on the road
to take on the Forty-Ninles.
The Ninles.
- The Ninles.
- Amendment 1 and Amendment 2.
- Aaron Rodgers, Kyle Shanahan.
We'll figure out our amendments.
Vikings could've lost that game
to the 49ers.
Green, Green Bay—
God bless you, and God bless
Aaron Rodgers.
- Yes.
- That guy really
strung together
some winning seasons,
huh, Simms?
- Wow, hey, I mean, I'm too—
I can't remember
what exactly I was gonna say.
- We built your franchise.
- Well, I mean, Parcells
didn't...s--t.
- Got him.
Peace, bro.
- Matchmaker, matchmaker,
make me a match.
- You're absurd.
- Hey, where's the pizza?
I'm Don Corleone.
I need to shave.
I'm five minutes old.
That's what they call a gyro?
That's how you say it? Gyro?
♪♪♪
No way.
Negative, Ghost Rider.
Negative, Ghost Rider?
Negative, Ghost Rider!
The pattern is full!
Negative, Ghost Rider.
The pattern is full.
[Singing in Spanish]
Simms and Lefkoe,
the players' show
makin' you feel better, man.
- That's what I'm talkin'
about, man.
- Sorry, I didn't tell you
I was gonna—
- Damn!
- I got excited!
Well, you were wrong.
You said Friday.
- Ooh ooh ooh!
- Don't touch me.
[Laughing]
Punch Big Ben in the leg!
Kick him in the d--k!
- [Laughing]
- How would he procure
such saltwater taffy?
- I don't know what "procure"
means
so you'll have
to explain that to me.
- [Laughing]
- How did he obtain the saltwater taffy?
- Hold on one second.
[Laughing]
For Simms.
- Peace out, homies.
- I am the L-E-F-key-O-E—
- Man.
He's the K-O-E. He'll learn
how to spell his name
on the next episode
of "Simms & Lefkoe: The Show."
Till then, we'll have him in the
back, learning how to spell.
- What just happened?